um
oh it is detecting my stream okay that's
good
well
this'll be much different than normal
because I have time to think and explain
and interact with the chats hello to
people in the chat
hello professional hello on Achatz hello
Ariel is taken um
yeah hopefully the audio and video look
okay I'm playing Knight c3 here
you
Locke does have to be careful playing d5
there are cases where the center opens
up in White's favor I'm going to take
this is actually somewhat new position
for me
Bishop b5 looks attractive provoke some
kind of c6 and then move back
back to d3
you
ninety-five comes to mind with errands
into Bishop before a check
queen aphorism
[Music]
95 the move
when a 4 is a very typical idea to
someday play Bishop a6 and we can the
light squares
but I'm not gonna take too much time I'm
gonna go with my first instinct this
Bishop b5 c6 Bishop d3 and then
this is a fine position black will
probably play c5 at some points castle
complain hello ex villager good to see
you back
always in time for a stream
yeah I'm finally listening to feedback
people wanted to see longer games so we
have classical chess
not sure how long I'll last today but
hopefully I'll get some instructive
games in
I wanna play 95 here
h3 is another candidate move just safe
and solid
and
other candidate move like a three and
then before ideas
also rook c1 lots of moves moves to
consider here
trying to figure out if black is
actually threatening 9h v because if he
is I'll probably play h3
imagine rich z19 h5 Bishop e5
probably not while I go into that line
you could take and then have the bishop
pair replace e5 later
the page three
I'll often do I stream I mean for the
last 4 days I've been streaming I think
this is my fourth day in a row I'm not
mistaken it has been a bit infrequent
but
ah but yeah it depends on the month
well I've been streaming pretty
consistently
we're consistently meaning like at least
I had full of times every month it's not
not on a set schedule
you
to motae hello
2:00 a.m. where are you 11 a.m. here
2:00 a.m. it's gotta be in like
Australia
a possible
yeah Australia I guessed it I'm going to
Australia in December most lightly I was
actually just in Australia he months ago
I was in Brisbane Adelaide and Melbourne
and I want to go back and visit Sydney
one city I've heard good things about
on the top 10 streamer list Thank You
Annika
disappointed that I'm not top 5 what to
do
I guess I could be top 5 on top 10 a 50%
chance of that
so he plays rook e8 let's go for this
normal plan
interesting I usually play these types
of positions from the black side not
from the white side
it just feels different
I'm not sure if I work see ones the
right idea Burak be one in before
or some other move like clean
Queen c2 we need to
just gonna go with my gut Brooksie one
anytime that black goes for this night
maneuver the bishop will drop back to h2
and at least from my experience from the
backside it's not that easy to get
actively
and another idea for why this depends
potentially play Bishop H 295 and f4
it's some kind of stone wall structure
and facilitate some attack
I'm thinking that if he plays an f8 here
I'll start with Bishop h2
preparing that play one of these two
night moves and then I'll find 95
and then the position should be decent
he's debating another one he's debating
my that phase is by far the most natural
move as you could play c5 to
promisee five it weakened certain things
it allows me to take it some preferable
pollen structure also gives me the be 5
square
you play them as black and you would
know
if you play them as black then you would
know what you wouldn't like to be played
against you
to go from the starting position yeah
because I have time here we have a
London opening starting as this Queen's
Indian set up and against Queens Indian
I enjoy playing see for normal London
would be probably like c3 Bishop t3
let's see if we're has some traps to it
um one trap in particular is that if
black plays c5 here there's this d5 move
which is very strong leads to some pawn
sacrifice line but usually good for
white anyway uh game continued so he
goes for c5
I probably don't want to take on c5
necessary you might want to place C for
a Belgian novice longtime fan the
first-time viewer
thanks for the bits appreciate that
I usually don't stream this early in the
morning
by this early in the morning
I'm talking about 11 a.m.
plug in my laptop charger
so the there's a few cannon moved here
95 looks attractive might be five is
something to calculate weight might be
five might just be very strong
how does he defense e7
also has some positional thread of 96 to
get the bishop hair so my chief knight
b5 is clearly the first move to
calculate
throw in c4 but then I played Bishop to
be one
five
mean usually he would like to play a
move like 96 or 98 spit those are not
possible
so 95 rook c8 the very least I have 96
but I could take Brigade go back he
takes only 2
let's do it
you
that's a drawback for a back in this
position like this is in my control this
isn't my control this isn't my control
when you have so many squares in your
pones territory in your control good
things should happen
it's yeah this is a good time for the
Europeans very strange time for
Australians
so you please Ricky eight very quickly
as I guess a playable move
I'm winning anything here
I mean 96 looks I mean calculate 96
big take our custom back lineman upon
he doesn't take basis move
9:05
let's do it
you
you
trying to figure out the ship c6 here if
I have anything better than night of
five
really I'm I'm just content with getting
the bishop here it's a good enough
advantage
I'm ignoring people in the chats I like
it was saying I saw that I rated your
find Kurt movin Kurt's
and he was playing hand in brain I
didn't even know that's well you're
welcome
isn't the bishop I need to passive if I
play f4 yeah the bishop on each to like
if I went for this idea it would be
passive but I would gain space and then
maybe try and reactivate some day
but that would be the one downside with
playing some f4 idea
okay so he plays Bishop c6
the ship isn't defended on c6 I don't
know if there's any tactics 95 could be
a consideration
probably not good
yeah I'm just gonna go for a night of
five
the pressure at any time I can take on
you seven since Bishop has no squares
how long is a tournament you can see the
countdown here it's just over just under
ten hours left
oh and Sokolowski
specify that
me pants with a double +
so notification for me
i flattered
yeah this is not a mindless bullet
stream
too many of those so it's hopefully
gonna be a lot more instructive and I'll
have to all have a lot more time to
answer questions throughout so if anyone
has questions don't bombard me too much
but I will take questions
Nathan F good to see you asking if I'm
streaming for all ten hours I don't know
I don't like to commit beforehand if I
said I was in the stream for all ten
hours I would feel bad if I stopped so
and they'll play a handful of games
handful of games could be several hours
one game could last one hour
in the sky
guy in first place already has 11 points
maybe I should have dessert
I want to make a running in this
tournament
you
yeah I'm gonna stream until I feel like
I'm getting like just dead
and then I'll probably stop
but yesterday I think I went three hours
and then but I felt dead Amycus part of
Sun I've been told that I look like a
younger Kasparov
I come from Russian origin but I'm not
Kasparov son
the way Gotham chess in the chat
a levy thanks for hosting me with 80
viewers
I thought Gotham chess is lovey if he
just say hates himself
and so confused
shout out to Gotham chess we need more
Gotham chess in the world
Ches okay he wants to play Bishop f8
so now it's the question is my night
more powerful than his bishop
as I have so much attacking potential
like this is a type of position crew 64
would just like take this pawn or take
something sacrifice something and tatty
goes
but I've
a bit more controlled
so I'm searching for candidate moves
here 95 looks playable and g5 looks a
bit ambitious
but it's all about finding threats and
ways to perhaps drive some initiative
like 95 looks quite appealing because
when I take e5 pawn to e5
as night's attacks in 94 Queen g4
Bishop FA night h6 I win his queen
another variation could be
if he moves to d7
[Music]
that also looks nice for me let's play
95
my nights are menacing
okay I'll look at the chat again how
many comments I'm like I'm very far
scrolled up so I'm not looking at like
the most recent comments passed pawn 99
it's going well it's early for me but
it's my laptop not charging
I don't know how this happens but I plug
in the charger and then like a few
minutes later the charger will just be
completely unplugged I'm not touching it
like stuff happening I don't know
zurk every game yeah that's probably
good advice wait did levy host me
also are there notifications
because I had this problem yesterday I'm
so confused
there are notifications because Belgian
novice just subscribed thank you for
that Belgian novice you appreciate it
okay it's still blacks move let me go
ahead and open up stream labs login
down in chess asking who is crew 64
who's 64 is a ghost of the past he's
probably like haunting me right now and
just unplugging my laptop charger
it's a turn-on engine to understand a
joke
you
I do a Kasparov impression no Kasparov
impression is for crew 64 I don't do
impressions
I could try I'm may be doing a good
Kasparov impression with these Knights
currently
did levy really host me
I don't see any notification thank you
levy for hosting me if you hosted me
sometimes I'm just oblivious to things
happening
I don't even know where I am in the chat
down our IP
oh he didn't host me I'm
so confused
and chess
Gotham chess I will no longer say crew
64
Pratham chess
feels weird saying Gotham chess
effort
not even like so much chat
let me think the people who just
supported me sin sin kills or is that
sink ills eighty-five thank you for the
hundred bits
ah keeping a good impression and passed
pawn 99 thanks for southern
I do not have a sub command why is
Nathan not on God
Maude Nathan F b14
congratulations Nathan
and promoted and chats I have to figure
out how to allow mods to create commands
because that would be convenient is
there a way to do that with Moo box
you
gradually them
he earned it
I don't have a subs command I have a sub
command okay I'm gonna go in to move
back so much time to kill given this
classical game
but I apologize for
strong the position
these are my commands I don't know
people can see that
but
it's not the hole or it's not like
everything that I should have
[Music]
list so
create a sub subs commands creates
and then is there a way to like
say who the subscribers are
[Music]
I don't know how to do
that work
you
I just made the sub command
is it supposed to list off like the
usernames of subscribers
um oh by two elastic hold I didn't even
even say hi to him before but thanks for
watching sorry that I'm not putting much
focus on the game but we'll we'll get
back to this I'm gonna take with pawn
Thank You soccer for the follow take
your soccer I'm very happy about this
position this Knight has to move queen
g4 is about to come
the calculation I did before was 94
Queen g4 Bishop f8 night h6 check-in h8
and then I win the Queen
I'm probably not playing viewers today
if you want to play me you can join this
tournament and then I guess there's a
minut chance that will play but I'll do
a viewer stream reviewer challenge
stream later in the future
with the code
wait did anyone answer my question if if
like a mod can add a command
you
you
yeah I'll look into that
my to-do list okay so queen g4 is my
main move to consider here
and he can't play Bishop f8 you probably
have to play g6
also can I just take on g7
that looks so much fun
but is it sound
again a bullet game I just take on g7
right away or I play queen g4 right away
but in a classical game I have to think
queen h5 is another candidate move
so Knight to g7 Kinte queen g4 Keaney
Tibbets
then I'll go after the h7 pawns so like
Queen f5
nana fate
like e6 threatened Bishop e5
a relatively forcing line so take
actually he has no other option than to
go into this
as king I fit there's Bishop h6 mates
just to play in HX
oh maybe I play bishop I can play Bishop
h6 first
threatening means
and if you plays Bishop afaid I've
queena five
he can't is no longer any neither face
and that's a similar case if we start
the beginning take
you're here here if he plays rook GX
Ricky it could be an issue
I wanted to play Queen at five and then
use rook g6
you
I'll be trying too hard to make
let's work when I just have some simple
option
it's my simple option
you
Queen g4g 6:9 h6 wait now queen g4 g6
he's not threatening anything
some done maybe six
986
that looks a lot simpler night ag7 might
be good somehow applets
I wanna risk it
I want to do one more calculation queen
okay so I've confirmed that queen g4 is
just a safe option with easy six idea
but I want to look at one more line
after queen h5 threatening to take on
you seven
it doesn't have too many ways to defend
if he plays a semi of Bishop h6
in g8
should take our fates
we should take f8 is winning because can
take f8 queen h6 and then there's mates
might a g7 King take g7 Queen h5 rook
eight shades
age six which is also winning
is that winning
Erica cheats
h6 King g8 looks so good Queen g4 Bishop
g5 h g5 i takee 5
just trading stuff
no that's gotta be good I have at the
very least h4 after a Bishop g5 ok I'm
going for this
tick tick
wait there's one more line to consider
see southern Queen age five he plays f5
but then I can just pipe I should take
out five okay having fun
the thing in classical chess if you're
going to sacrifice you have to be pretty
sure that the sacrifice is working
um oh there's a bird flying by out the
window I was a distance away but I
thought it was like a really huge bug
peripheral vision anyway I don't know
why he's thinking here because any other
move
well I'll just be losing for him so he
basically has to test me
I'll get back to the chats hello Bruno
rola
like comer making an appearance
some mention of my comer ok queen h5
you
so there's a few threats here windigate
seven Bishop h6
I don't think you can defend everything
[Music]
you
I'm not gonna start predicting what
he'll play because I don't want him to
be like just watching and I'm listening
to him calculating I haven't given him
enough information already so
lastic hold is asking 97
yes I calculated
the slime way elastic hold is still here
ah
so I did calculate
it's probably the most intuitive line
but I didn't see what to do after 9f8
defending if I play Bishop h6 he has 96
so here the difference is that if he
plays a night of fades I just play
Bishop h6 and take the Knights and it's
winning for whites
Oh mods can add commands on nightbot
interesting
let me install my part my part which
hopefully it's relatively easy sign up
login
authorized
okay nightbot is authorized
odds you can take it from here if I need
to do anything more
maybe join channel
my pots there you go okay
on my part
hey I have 27 subs okay
I guess could nightbot and moobot
conflict
if I have like a subs command for each
well thank you Nathan
so now I guess any anemic now add a
command and thank you I weave the one
bit um pick moobot rar
I'll chessboard his back
so okay this guy's thinking I think next
game I'll berserk its given this is
pretty slow-paced extra kuhar thanks for
subbing
should I mute moobot no moobot has
commands - oh but I guess nightbot does
everything that moobot does
except that that pushing baby commands
annals taking off is that a good thing
or a bad thing you like going away or
going up in the world
my opponent is probably just crying in
this position
this is one of these moments like I wish
it was over the board chest just to see
my opponents suffer in real life
I weave thank you for the follow and
there is a ten second increments so he
could get low on time and then perhaps
play on for longer
so
I wonder if he did you know as though
I'm streaming as it doesn't show though
I don't think it showed this alert when
I started the game if I were to refresh
the page it would show the alert pretty
sure but he probably doesn't see this
so hopefully that's a good thing
if you're watching say hi in the chats
okay please Noah Fitz
just a double check here here take and
life is good
there's actually some cute force mates
let's imagine kingi ate it all now it's
happening
King take FA Queen h6 King g8
Bishop take here here here
he never minds
trying to be fancy
so here I just wanted to take well I
also have on pissant
antacids
you
I mean okay everything wins just trying
to find the most efficient win
okay I might as well just save the
bishop
or I could I could do this you can't
take the bishop because Queen take aged
seven mates
Bishop t7 or Queen d7 I can play e6 do
that
I'm trying to figure out my threat
though I give it's White's move in this
position the thread is probably just
Bishop h6 with the main threats
elastic old asking about emotes everyday
yeah I have not pirate eyes demos I need
to put together a list of like emote
requests
at six
do this
I'm threatening meat and I'm threatening
his bishop I don't think you could
defend both
Londyn emotes I'm going to London in
like two weeks
I'll try and do a stream okay he resigns
uh real quick have some closure on the
scheme
I don't want computer analysis just yet
I like the opening and we got some
Queens gambit declined position Black
was a bit passive 95 was nice and my
nights were beautiful
yeah I think I take g7 is strongest I
was going to play
when g4
- suckers say
Wow +6
g7 nice wait a minute so I have really
have no - I played perfectly Lackey
I mean 16 average sent upon loss is
pretty good
um he's slightly suspicious but I mean
all the moves were natural a knight a g7
was one of these like if it works it
works
queen h5 i think i guess this is a hard
thing to realize is queen like it's so
easy to get caught up in this is queen
g4 lens I was very close not to playing
not playing might take g7 because I
didn't see what happens after Queen g4
it was good I came back to it and just
considered Queen h5 you always got to
consider that the forcing moves like
Queen g4 is obvious forcing move but
Queen h5 is also a forcing move because
it's just threatening mates so ok that
makes me feel good it starts back to
tournaments
some catching up to do only one game
people are so far ahead